>>> TO TEAE TRUTH
RALR
HEAY FROM PRESIDENT OFNE OF THL
RE TEACHERS TEACH
RACISM I
>> THE OF
PARENTN SPEAKING
CRT.E MY B NOT YOURS.
YOURNO NOR MY AT'S
ep A SCHOOL
D OF
PHILLY.
OUP ARE KIUTT CRITICAL RACE EOR
DON'T WANT OUR CHIN AUGHERICA I.
>> DON'T REWRITETU
PROTESTS OF THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD, REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS
VENG CRITI
RY TO THE
IMPRESSION
AMERICA'S CHILDREN
L RACE S A RACIST.
ICr: IN MORE THAN 12
STATES, LEGISLATOR
BILLS TO BAN.TED TO MEET THE PEE
KI IN
ACTUAL
WED TOIAAMDISCUSSES  HER LOGY C
WITH, WHATE THEORY
>>CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS NO
BEING TAUGSCHOOLS.
CONNECTSN SOCIET AVIEW STORY IN
SOME TEACHERS TEACH?
Y  BLOCK
T TALKorter: CL RACE
THCIALD BYIN  LRE
THPLE AND ESPECIALLY
WHITILRE UNDER ATT THEORY EO HA
IDEOLOGY FORCINGMBRACING THI
STUDENTS AND TEACHERE
ASHAMED S RACISM
>> THESE ARE SYSTEMIIGNORING IE.
BY ACKNOWLEDGING IT,CA
WE CAN ADDRESS THEROEM UALITY T.
PEOPLEr: ARE YOU TEACHING  AMER.
I'M TEACHINGLD AHA
PAT. FORCEULAR WORLD VTHEY CAN T
S IT INSANE?
>> IA
>> Reporter: LAST YEAR, THISN R
THWOULD BE LEAG
MOREBOUTE.
SHE THOUGHT THMATERIALS WERE
HER KIDS OU
PUBLIC SCHOOL.E CRTEA O
OISONING YOUNGER CLAIM THAT CR
IN THEE PENALTY
BECAUSE D --
>> ASK BIDENHY HE DID
THAT.
A GREAT
QUESTION.
JOE BIDEN IS AILLUSTRATION.
JOE BIDEN WO
AS AICE GUY WHO WOULD NEVEHAVE .
IPATED
STRUCTURAL AFFECT O
BLK THAN WHITE.
ALARE TALKING ABOUT
NOW.
ISR MO
I DON'T WANT ITO
INDOCTTE KIDS THAT WILL HA
EIR SKINK THEM.
WH T SUM
TWISTED THE MINDS CABEBY
ANTIS  BLM KIDS IF THEY
KIDS.
THEY AREEL, THEY WERE DOCTRID.S.
>> Reporter: WERE YO A?
BR ON
BEATP IFA 'M TALKING, IT'SOI
HAPPEN IF WE ARE NOT TO
STOP IT.BU GOIO STOP IT.
WE A.
WE ARE THE GREAT MAJORITY OF
TH
>> Reporter: AT PROPAGNG CRO
MORE THAN 100 PEOPLE SHOD UP
HERE NEAR BALTIMORER
S HELD A PANEL
ON SCHOOL COVID D
ITICAL RACE TH
>> CRITICAL RACE TOR
IDT'S TAUGHT T
NOTHING.eporteANY T THU ARE BORR
EORY
BABLY NOT.eporter: CAN YOU NAME
EOT? I SUMMARIZED CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AS A WHOLE PRETTY WELL. G
I THINK ISANGEUSeporte
THE CONSTITUTION IN ICE COUNTEDA
PERSON.
>> THAT WAAT AN ASorter: YOU ME
FOUNDING OF THE COUNTRY.>>EA
IT WASN'T PERFECTLY WRITTEN IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Reporter:N U FIRST
HEARD ABOUT CRITICAL RACRY?
>> AROUND LAST YEAR.
>> Repor WHERE DID YOU SEE
IT?
>> ON FOX WS
>> THE IDEU CAN SUCCEED ON YOUR.
BECAUSE OF Y COLORS  TU CANNOT
SUCCULINT  PERIOD.CH BOOKS M
ANTHROPOLOGY CLASS.
O HATE THEMSELVEING  TEACHING
N
eporter: ARE TDST THERE ISVE TH.
THEY C FT O  THERE'S RACISM AND
ABSOLELY NOT.VE
I'CREATINGRE FUTUREICIANS ANDRS
AND CMAKERS.
R .
AT'S HAPPENING.
I O THEM ASERVICE
ISSUE WHEN I JS TO LEARN THE
ICHI T VOTERS.LY D BECOM
SCARINGF
PEOPLE.
THEY KON
GE THESE
PARENTS IN PHILLY.
YOU HAVE DONE SO MUCRTING
ON THIS.
HOW SP IN.
SECTS OVERRTCOUNTR BY ONG
IF T
UT IT.ID.
WHTH
BASED ONATION, THE